What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity.
Since you guys loved triangle
table tennis so much
We are back with a new table set up
One game to 11 points of Z-Pong
Let's go!
I get to start.
You still have no chance.
0-0
I have too much power
No!
Run!
This is so tough!
I'm very sorry Otto.
No! How can I miss that?
Roller!
Coming!
Nooo!
Close.
Cheeky
Coming!
I've got a good serve coming up
Okay
It's coming up!
It was a good serve!
The ball just disappeared and suddenly
it's over there!
Sorry!
I'm not sorry!
You fought well
But in the end it was obvious
Thanks.
Let us know in the comments if you have any cool table
set up ideas
And don't forget to hit subscribe!
Until next time!